si vous aimez le doute sur ça au niveau
des claviers ben vous avez un truc qui
est vachement bien chez Asus c'est le
rogue adroc on peut venir totalement
personnaliser son clavier pour avoir une
expérience unique on peut venir
travailler sur la sensibilité de ses
touches toucher retour de touche c'est
nouveauté que nous montre Asus ici qui
est super chouette en plus vous avez ici
un petit écran au LED sur le côté on
peut venir paramétrer beaucoup de choses
il pèse son petit pois je trouve super
on a un super beau retour de douche
l'arrêt c'est le rogue azote je vous
invite à aller jeter un coup d'œil parce
que ça franchement si vous voulez
totalement personnaliser votre
expérience avec un clavier gaming qui
n'est pas du tout comme les autres là
vous avez vraiment de quoi faire
d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires